Hello, everybody. Dr. Cutters. This is section four of the beating chronic line book.
I hope you're learning something. Hope this is new to you. Well, I hope you're going to gain something from it.
Okay, so always in any of these contact our office if you have any questions
as we go here and it's new to you and it's hard to understand or listen to it again or read it again, go over it again.
Tell notes of a way other books my
auto view book gives you more detail in the auto view picture of it. So
today we're going to talk about barriers. There's very important aspect
what you're dealing with any chronic disorder. You have certain barriers in your body, barriers
against disease. Your skin is a barrier. Keeps things out of your body. Your gut
lining is a barrier. It keeps things out of your body. Yes, things that are in your gut cavity,
food that you just ate that has not yet been absorbed is still outside of your body even if it's in
your intestines. It doesn't actually get inside your body until it crosses the gut barrier. So the
intestinal barrier is a barrier to keep poisons out of your body. It's supposed to only absorb certain
things and when we have a breakdown of that barrier wall all of a sudden all sorts of enemies can get
through and that's not a good thing. That's called intestinal permeability. Well, we're talking about
live disease. It didn't, you didn't swallow it. So it's not getting across that barrier. Of course,
a tick bit through your skin barrier. So you have a break in that barrier. Well, there's not a
whole lot we can do. We can't wear armor when we go outside. So that tick got on your skin. It bit
through the skin barrier. It broke that barrier. But the most concerning thing that we want to deal with
with live disease is typically in chronic line and in autoimmune line, especially when you have a
varied debilitated disorder, it has broken through the blood brain barrier. So there's a skin
barrier. There's a gut barrier. There's a cellular barrier. There's an endothelial barrier as far
as your blood vessels go and there is a blood brain barrier. So we're going to talk about the blood
brain barrier. In the brain you see how this picture, the lower picture, which I can circle, it says
astrocyte. Your astrocytes are a type of glial cells in the brain that what are the things they do
is they form these very tight junctions up against your blood vessels. So up against where it says
the basement membrane, there's actually a smooth muscle layer there. So this is a very simplified
picture. And then where the purple it says endothelium. The endothelium is a single layer of
cells, endothelial cells. There are epithelial cells that's lining the bloodstream. It's a
single layer of cells that line the blood. So there is the fluid of the blood on the top there. So the
fluid of the blood, so if that's the inside of a blood vessel, is surrounded by endothelial cells
and then a basement membrane which includes the muscular tissue. And then you have the astrocytes
that border all around that cylindrical blood vessel in the brain. So it lets through, that's a
barrier. It only lets through very selective things. That is a difficult thing when they're creating
pharmaceuticals that they want to treat something in the brain as having something to be able to
cross through that blood brain barrier. Now the problem is there's things that break that blood
brain barrier. And infections are one of those. So if we have an infection like a lime infection,
it can break the blood brain barrier. But many, many people that have chronic lime or have a stage
three line, auto-vealed line already the reason why they moved. Remember I said there's a window
of opportunity to treat it. Well one of the reasons why that window could be smaller. So one person,
they get a tick bite in that window of opportunity. It has not yet gone into the cell and it has not
yet broken the blood brain barrier. And it might last 30 days and they can take antibiotics,
knocking out, kill it completely. And another person that could last three days. And it already
got into the cell, already crossed the blood brain barrier. They're already getting neurological symptoms
because of it. And they just got this tick bite five days ago. Well they already had damaged
barriers. So this person wasn't quite as healthy as another person. That's typically the case.
And it doesn't mean that they have a chronic disorder or anything but they could have had a head
trauma. They could have had all sorts of things that damaged the blood brain barrier previous to the
lime disorder. Now understand lime and itself could damage the blood brain barrier. I know I'm
talking really fast but I got a lot of slides to go through here. So understand any barriers. It's
very, very, very important to understand that it's this damage of the blood brain barrier that allows
lime to cross over it. And what's that happens? We have a pickle on our hand. We end up having
inflammation in the brain. So you have inflammation in the brain just because there's there's
infiltration of a bacteria. So when it when a infection infiltrates into the brain you activate
another type of glial system. A glial cell is these different cells that are in the brain,
not the neurons but the glial cells. And I said the astrocytes were one type of glial cell that
actually forms the blood brain barrier but microglial cells are really the immune system of the brain
and that causes an inflammatory response. So here's a picture of schematic. We're not going to go over
this really strongly but there's one point of the schematic that's really important. When you activate
microglial cells because you have an infection in the brain. So if I have an infection in the brain
because of a lime disorder, I activate microglial cells and what that does is it
up-regulates. It does a lot of things. This is a really important thing because it causes a lot
of symptoms. It up-regulates glutamate production. Glutamate is acts as a neurotransmitter of the
brain and it causes an up-regulation of a lot of different brain functions and that is not
what we want. So some of the symptom patterns of a person with with Lyme disease especially in
the early stages when it infiltrates the brain is this up-regulation glutamate and that could cause
what we call brain-unfire. So when you look at it through the eyes of looking at a brain skin
you see this blue area in the brain especially in the temporal and frontal areas which is
a picture of what we call brain-unfire this rig of fire in their brain. It's highly up-regulated
and in this case we see alpha and beta and theta waves. So the different brain waves are very
up-regulated. It can cause a lot of anxiety, a lot of ADD, ADHD type symptoms and just some
brain fog and just a lot of dysregulation and just a lot of the brain symptoms to just see with
the person with chronic Lyme. So again the three phases of Lyme acute stage you have that window
of opportunity that you want to treat it with an antibiotic chronic stage is where the person still
does a real well-treat with cat's claw vitamin C herbals that will stimulate a TH1 reaction. If you
are not getting really good results like phenomenal results with TH1 stimulators you'll see a list of
those in the book. You are probably already in the autoimmune stage and we're going to be talking
about that in our next couple of slides or next couple lectures. So this takes you through the section
that you're reading today. Again if you ever have any questions you can contact our office. Again we
only accept cancer and chronic Lyme patients right now at least while I'm taping this. So I hope this
is helpful for you and we'll see you at the next section.